hello welcome to see you playing the
jack you later with white surname is
their name there isn't any okay so we
get a Sicilian here let's see what he
plays the time on off maybe yeah the
tomorrow i'm currently studying the open
sicilian with white but the tomorrow i
have not looked at yet um what you do
here I mean there are some solid lines
like g3 or something like that there's
also a 4 based stuff I come on guys what
is this and who calls you in chess games
yeah so Quinn to c7 and now I'm
completely am completely out of focus so
what do I do here okay let's play a same
move then no this isn't what I meant
with out of focus shoot em Wow well okay
probably isn't totally terrible h5 yeah
something like h5 maybe okay it doesn't
do that and I just let's play normal
moves Ned's weekend f3 is weak
yeah I was thinking this isn't actually
that terrible i have 92 and ken can put
it can put it back on whatever get rid
of the night the night will be three is
not positioned right anyway so let's put
this on a normal square you should age
three so black is of course completely
fine him so a little bit too that's too
tame what what I play here threatening
to take now on d2l stupid shouldn't have
allowed that okay
we see taking with a pawn yeah that's a
possibility not sure if it's doing all
that much I'm just trying to get this
night to a decent square i am on d1 this
is not looking good there once III I'm
sorry it is not looking good so here
just moves night to d2 later Quincy 293
yeah it's not so easy here actually if I
take two to excavate its to activate
stuff I could have played be three
actually immediately maybe that was a
little bit better hmm it was maybe a bit
better to do it to do that immediately
so what's going on here is he going for
f5 or something like that can you have
one you can actually take here Queen
takes work to create one mate Oh matter
is dangerous Bishop f3 yeah maybe this
Sun King 2 or something just keep the
status quo here
I'm not quite sure I theory should
really open up like that but currently
he is threatening him yeah come on let's
let's let's get rid of this active night
not taking no it's taking so let's let's
get this going and see if this really
helped him this f5 move I'm not sure
about this weekend since position quite
a bit I mean I'm not saying I'm better
than her not but I felt that without f5
this was even more problematic and good
movie it's a good move
time morning bloody that's a good move
yeah
when I was a running game from the
beginning right with the ever I totally
I'd have to switch off my my my phone
and I really hate it like nothing else
in the world that they call me during a
chess game I usually just grew up me no
matter what yeah the upon already
promoting on I mean the sea point is
quite quick here what's the problem
checking me here hmm this is clear on
the sky better probably probably he can
can you prepare show me hear me no not
so easy check check check
yeah probably have to make the drone
here check draw offered check yeah I
have to make it draw offered nothing I
can gain drawn wow that was a lucky
escape there was a rotten game from the
get-go yeah then you get I'm totally
totally put out of things about that
phone call and then bishop age 3 m crazy
yeah okay this is still I mean if I just
go back probably it shouldn't be all
that terrible but I was playing a quiet
passively the whole game as you see I
mean okay don't see as you see a black
is a bit better here according to the
engine which is kind of normally the
Constructors favoring lucky Nia's play
on the C file and I have basically not
much the only thing i have is relatively
decent centralization so i shouldn't
fall apart quickly but black is fine
very fine and it was an interesting way
of playing I just think that he should
just play here I think this is simpler
to be honest continue with this
structure I mean the way it was I was
also worse but I felt this is even more
of a problem if he just goes back to
this thing and yes his Fred and he can
like improve easily I hope da door yeah
I first of all I have to go back and I
rook da don ok I don't know I I thought
this was even even more of a problem but
well I mean the way it went I was just
watch the suffering him I should play be
three now him the lame this was a
mistake and all this f5 him ok I was
tired of being so passive so I went with
this this
quick Queenie amonos may be better at
all yeah the engines suggestion I whoa I
cannot cake yeah that's very bad that
they're just losing and it's really not
a surprise that he had some some winning
continuations but I don't think like
here that this is all that clear I force
the less yeah but here it gets very
tricky for a while it's a brutal move
yeah but he can probably catch alright
so that's who very very hard to play
such a thing with her with the limited
time as human being yes so here did have
something else not king kings c6 now I'm
completely winning with Quincy form I
had two queens two queens do the trick
right okay huh yeah because it's a bit
much sherrod no not this air first
checking no taking this okay what so
this is winning crazy has no decent
check even though he has two queens Wow
ok none that sets out of out of my
ability I mean yeah with lots of time I
would probably consider Quincy forward I
mean I was really happy that I'm
basically having a freeroll here he has
to
either has to a perpetual me or if I
cannot avoid it it's a draw then but I
have this f6 and stuff on them well so I
lucky escape there thanks for watching